welcome back to the crazy story in
eSports where this week riot is walking
back a ban an eSports org is exploding
and a Korean senator is taking a victory
lap yeah this [ __ ] just got crazier
again
all right so here comes the part of the
video where I try to recap three videos
and like under a minute so bear with me
Griffin is a team in the lck whose coach
CV max left abruptly before the World
Championship it turns out he had a
pretty bad falling-out with their
manager a guy named Joe then there were
allegations that show strongarm a player
called Konami into signing an
unfavorable contrast now Konami is a
minor and a crane senator was
investigating that case more on that in
a minute
toe resigned but maintained that CV max
was still in the wrong then allegations
began to fly that CV match was verbally
and physically abusive towards players
and ride stepped in and banned both Joe
and CV max indefinitely see according to
that Korean Senator a guy called tag
Jung ha kanabi was effectively tricked
by Griffin and sho now Konami again is a
minor and ha alleges that they tricked
him into signing an unfavorable contract
that allowed them to ship him off to a
Chinese team against his will and
without his knowledge
senator ha also published what he
alleges is Konami contract which
includes [ __ ] up clauses like that
they could fire him for being in the
hospital for more than 30 days senator
ha also said that CD Max's punishment
was abhorrent and that riot could be
punished under a law that protects
whistleblowers meanwhile CV max defended
himself by saying that his words were
being taken out of context and that
right wouldn't let him listen to their
recordings of him and if you want any
more info on all of that
please watch our 3 other videos on the
subject I actually have no idea where I
should be pointing right now anyway now
that all of that is out of the way we
actually have new developments because
the story keeps getting crazier alright
starting with the big stuff
Griffin basically allowed all of their
players to terminate their contract on
the spot leading to a couple of them
becoming free agents see the problem was
that there were other players signed to
Griffin who had contracts similar to the
one that Senator ha published that he
said was Konami so contracts that
included being able to be fired for
being the hostile for more than 30 days
being able to be fined and fired if they
can't get in contact with you being able
to be fired without telling you for any
reason whatsoever messed up stuff on
November 25th still 8 Griffin's parent
company released the statement saying
that they avoided all contracts for
different players including those with
the clauses that Senator ha brought up
still 8 then drafted a new contract and
allowed players to choose if they wanted
to sign it or become
agents as a result Lorenz Doran and Cho
V have all left the team Griffin is left
with sword rather Tarzan cabbie and
Viper all right
that's one of the big stories that's
everything who with the players for now
the other big piece of news is that riot
Korea announced that they were
suspending CV Max's band for now as a
reminder CV max was initially banned
because riot said that he verbally and
physically abused players that he was
coaching and they found evidence to that
fact according to their official
statement as translated by Kevin came of
Corizon riot says that they chose not to
release any of their evidence to the
public in order to protect their players
as a reminder CB max said that ryan
wouldn't let him listen to the tape of
his allegedly verbal abuse in the
statement ride korea writes that they
understand that the public has lost some
trust in them due to their decision and
process and thus are suspending cv max's
indefinite ban until they reinvestigate
the situation specifically they've hired
a third party group to investigate the
whole thing and they're going to be more
transparent and take testimony from both
sides
as an aside they specifically note that
they're gonna take testimony from both
sides here which implies to me that they
didn't take it before and that's kind of
messed up did they not talk to Stevie
Max or something I actually don't know
that is a real question anyway right
also said that show is not getting a
second chance right now
his indefinite ban will stick for now
and they're investing allegations that
he used verbal threats in his
conversations with kanabi on top of that
Konami has been released from his
contract by riot making him a free agent
finally riot also wrote that still eight
needs to reveal their entire managerial
connection with Griffin and they need to
replace all of the guilty parties before
the summer 2020 promotion tournament I
have no idea why they're being given
such a deadline that is a long time from
now also do they mean the entire Griffin
management as a replaced or the entire
still 8 management has be replaced the
statement is really unclear and I
honestly have no clue according to some
news articles it's the Griffin
management but again I'm not quite sure
anyway they have to be replaced or when
Griffin could be forced to forfeit their
lck spot in between all these crazy
announcements over the last few days
there was some pretty crazy stories that
came out for example can obvious mom did
an interview where she said that she had
no idea her son was being blown to a
Chinese team until she heard CB max's
tell-all stream that's pretty messed up
and
it's particularly weird when you
consider that Konami was a minor so he
would have had to have had a parent in
the room where he signed the contract
that said that would happen and it's
even weirder when you consider that
Riots interim announcement about the
whole thing said that Kenobi's contract
situation was actually above war so what
the [ __ ] happened here I actually have
an explanation for it but we're gonna
get to that in a minute until then
here's a few more pieces of info
according to translations of the
interview Kenobi's mom asked Joe about
how much money he'd get from this whole
loan situation and then he said that she
was obsessed with money that's a really
nice thing to say to the mom of a player
you just totally screwed over and now
that we're through on the other side and
all the players seem to be safe let's
talk about the craziest part of this
story the forged seals and I'm really
excited about this so here's what
happened according to Senator ha when
Konami signed his contract he signed
away his legal representation to a law
firm called Veet that's a v EA t now V T
is actually Griffin's legal consulting
firm and they also run a law firm called
key & Partners which is a player
representation from fun fact Konami and
his parents both say they've never
spoken with anybody at V or K and P
anyway senator Haas saying that veep
being both Griffin's legal counsel and K
and P being an organization owned by
them and representing the players is
extremely illegal under Korean law so
why didn't Griffin do this well the
answer according to senator ha is
actually pretty simple see in order to
get the loan to go through Konami his
parents were unlikely to let their son
get shipped off to China for god knows
how long
so especially without a guarantee of
extended pay for him so Griffin needed a
way to make the loan happen so that they
could get that sweet sweet transfer
money if Konami signed his
representation away to Veet they could
in theory act on his behalf and set up
for him to be alone to any team of their
choosing without asking him because
again beat would be Kenobi's legal
representation they would stand in for
his guardian and he seems to have signed
that right away to them and it seems
pretty [ __ ] crazy that anybody would
sign away their rights like that unless
they were completely fooled this is all
super [ __ ] up and it feels like him in
like a John Grisham novel or some [ __ ]
but this is actually happening this
really happened at least according to
senator ha
according to senator Javy even
advertised that they helped kanabi get a
loan they advertised that on their site
and they deleted the posts when the
whole investigation started
senator ha also says that when he met
with Griffin on October 24th
they said the kanabi didn't actually
have any legal representation weird now
in order for kanabi to have signed the
contract that allowed me to represent
him and loaned him off to China without
his consent
kanabi parents would have had to have
read the contract agreed to it and
signed it with him and obviously they
didn't because they don't remember any
of that happening but apparently they
did sign the contract because kanabi got
loaned off to China so what the hell
happened well according to Senator Haas
they were tricked fooled bamboozled
allegedly a Griffin employee came to
their house and told him that the
contract just had a few updates to the
foreign loan policy obviously that
wasn't true that part of the contract
they skipped over allegedly contained
lots of shady and sometimes illegal
clauses again that one where they could
fire him for being in the hospital
apparently Griffin went as far as to put
unnecessary seals all over the document
to convince Kennedy's parents that
Griffin was the only party involved in
the contract not vite I'm just gonna
pause here because this is super
important in Korea SEALs are basically
like the signatures for a company you
just stamp the document and that counts
as the company signing off on it anyway
Griffin seal very closely resembles the
key and partner seal again key and
partners is the agency owned by V that
represents the players on Griffin anyway
Griffin seal just so happens to look
like the key in partner seal remember
them there meets player representation
arm and Griffin allegedly used that to
their advantage according to senator ha
Griffin made a fake version of key and
partner seal and use it to sign the
contract to make key and partners which
is actually V Kannagi z' official legal
representation senator Haas says he
compared the seal on Kaname contract to
the seals on other Griffin's player's
contract and found the differences
senator Howe also alleges that Griffin
already signed the contract with these
allegedly forged seals before Kaname and
his parents even saw them so this was
apparently pretty premeditated the
question now becomes why the [ __ ] would
you go through all this trouble
to scam a player according to senator ha
it's because it allowed them to hide the
whole improper slave contract thing
allegedly the causes in the contract
that cannot be signed off on allow Qian
partner or fee to finalize any contract
on his behalf
use his funds and basically sub license
his contract to a third party without
his consent if that's all true it's a
pretty massive failure on Griffin's part
to protect the player especially bad
considering he's a minor
senator ha also called Griffin's action
those of a thuggish pimp which honestly
that's hilarious
anyway if you bounce off all that legal
nonsense here it is in as simple terms
as I can make it Griffin wanted players
on unfair contracts because it meant
they could load them out to other teams
whenever they wanted and collect sweet
sweet transfer dollars so they had a
legal firm create a player's agency that
they made players sign with and and it
was all good the problem is that Konami
was a minor and in order to get him to
sign on to that contract they needed to
trick his parents - with everything
threatening to fall apart they forged
the seals trig the parents and got
Konami under the slave contract when he
questioned what was going on with the
contract they threatened him and
eventually it Hulk started leaking out
and that Choa threatening Konami seems
to have been the jumping-off point for
this whole thing weirdly enough all that
stuff with CD Max just so happened to
come out at the same time and seem kind
of unrelated so senator ha is calling
for Griffin and still eight to be
investigated by the Korean government
for the legal association of Korea to
investigate the issue of seal forgery
for the fair trade commission to audit
everything and ensure that there are no
other victims in this whole contract
scandal and for the lck and KeSPA to
punish Cho and everyone else involved in
such a way that they can never harm
anyone like this in eSports again and to
finish it off senator Haas says he has
some good news coming down the pike so
maybe next time I update you guys we
have a happy ending to this whole thing
please how about I just do this and I
like a look like what the [ __ ] and throw
it away and then grab the
can you talk through the duck sorry I
didn't mean to actually throw it and
then yeah all right yeah I'm gonna be
like I just toss it and I'll grab my
skirt
all right